one so here I want to show a simple
technique which was using improve lower
bunk can be turning into algorithms
especially shrinkage and a random
restriction approach so let's first
review as its technique which was used
to prove formular lower bounds so here
I'm considering de mogan formulas it's
just a binary tree where the internal
nodes are and and all gates the leaves
are literals so for the random
restriction I want to do it a step by
step so you're repeatedly pick up verbal
randomly and random the fake say to be
as r01 they're using this approach so if
you think of each in the video leave by
randomly fixative you can eliminate the
1.5 leaves on average and then given
this circuit formula of size srn verbals
if you pick a verbal randomly and fix it
expectation you can reduce the size by
this 1.5 times the average frequency as
over n so this is upper bounded by this
so if I do this step by step until there
are appealing verbals left unfixed that
society is going to shrink by a factor
of P 21.5 so this one pound of 5 and 0
record the shrinkage exponent for the
gimmick inform your sides and this 1.5
is actually not optimal it was shown by
her stuff that is one point this
shrinkage exponent can be improved to be
almost 2 as these two is actually a limo
so you can construct a a de Morgan
formula of quadratic asides that compute
parity exactly so that means the
shrinkage the opponent cannot be
improved about to so this is ginger
under random restrictions was you wanted
to prove from their size a lower bunk
that it directly gives that parity
requires so if you can show some model
circular models that has shrinkage
exponent gamma that directly implies
parity requires size and do gamma and I
start sorry and you actually constructed
contracted a simple function which also
doesn't have good shrinkage in a
required size n 2 gamma plus 1
minus little one and by hostile result
this cave it's a familiar size lower
bound almost n 2 powers three so that's
the best known formula sighs lower bound
we have now so recently this shrinkage
approach were strengthened to
concentrate the shrinkage so previously
we say as a shrinkage of laminar size in
expectation he returns Jensen it to be
shrinkage with high probability so here
I am considering a different family of
restrictions let's correlate the Brady
restrictions where it's simple at each
step uses the paper the most of frequent
verbal appearance and formula and a
random to fix it so it can be proved
that if you do this after n minus P n
steps then with the probability
exponentially close to one so from their
size is going to be upper bounded by two
times it's like the expected size this
can be proved using assume a singing
quality for Superman ting kills so this
approach can be viewed as an algorithm
where you do this branching level the
level at each level you pick the most
frequent verbal and be able two branches
by fixing the verbal to be zero in one
bronze one in the other branch now this
shrinkage property can be turning into
set five bility algorithms so let's
suppose we started with a formula of
sizes sin and verbose and I can choose
this appeal to be one over some constant
times C square so by the previous
shrinkage property I can argue that I do
this greedy restriction for n minus
appealing levels I can argue that most
of us branches will have from their size
at most half appear so for all the
branches I will have p.m. verbose left
unrestricted but for most of those
branches the formulas eyes are very
small hoppip Ian okay so that means for
a set of viability algorithm for this
small for the branches with spa
familiars you just to prove for a search
on those verbose that are left on the
small formulas and then for the tiny
fraction where the from your size does
not shrink while you can also do brew
for
search on the remaining verb so after a
build-up this this branching tree I can
just count as a member of satisfying
assignment on the leaves of this
branching tree that it gives a subset
algorithm and the total running time is
going to be bounded by this amount so
this algorithm is not trivial for say to
be let's say less than square root
button but a using memorization
technique I can somehow improve the
algorithm for larger size so suppose we
start with formulas of size n to 2.49
zinc in this case I can choose P to be a
very small fraction so I want to
restrict or about the end to 0.001
verbals so I wish sugar or but such
small number of virgos and we can argue
that most of branches after n minus PN
levels of restrictions will have
formulas of sub linear size and then I
can just build up a lookup table to
enumerate all possible formulas of such
size and use that lookup table to speed
up satisfiability checking at the bottom
levels so that gives improved rang it
sorry run time like this but for size
larger than this year now since we know
that the shrinkage is conan for the
movie inform disease too so decides so
the same algorithm can be somehow
generalized for a larger size so
essentially in a recent world by tau if
you've an algorithm that again the runs
in same time but for size n 22.99 it's
like em to gamma plus 1 minus some
little constant so this matching with
matches with the best-known former size
lower bound we have
so the step back and look at this
algorithm it's very actually very simple
so it's it's like DP era of style
branching algorithm accepts that
memorization park okay so after the
higher level so we start with an
extensible size s and so I want to do
created restriction to shrink dissonance
sides by this vector P to gamma so I
just need is a sort of happen with high
probability and at the end I will have
very small shrink the distance so
depending on the parameters were SNP I
guys are using some known algorithm to
solve these small instances or i can use
memorization so but for the small
fraction where the shrinkage does not
happen i can use brute force search so
it's simple according to a template of
reasons now let's see how can use such a
template to solve some other problems
okay before that so when thats easy size
s it can I sure to be generalized to be
a way to function or general mayor so
people have trying to use this matter
with a function in order to improve the
shrinkage opponent and if we can improve
shrinkage opponent in it implies better
algorithm so now let's see how to use
the same algorithm solves parts max set
so in this setting where a given a CNF
but we see n number of clauses I want to
find a certified I want to find an
assignment that satisfies a maximum
number of clauses so here I want to put
a measure on this instance the mare is
actually like to be so you just put the
mirror 0 on one classes marijuana and
two causes and married to one or other
clothes is no matter how how long your
cause is and then using greedy
restriction it at MP argue that you can
have shrinkage exponent 2 for this kind
of burger oh sorry I forgot mesh so the
mayor of the Holy instance is just that
the salvation was married on using in
the video class
and then after this shrinkage where you
can choose a specific appear to be in
the other one over C and you can argue
that after I do this n minus P and
creative is chicken chicken for in my GP
n steps most of the branches are going
to end up with almost all all of the
closets are one causes so you might have
some very few number of lung classes but
there are very few so you can do it
nightly to a link eliminate longhouses
and then for the smoke clouds easy you
can solve X 1 set in polynomial time for
the small fraction where shrinkage does
not happen you to brute-force search
this gives this running time like this
so this algorithm was first used by sake
settle and Tamaki brazier as you were
using the matter as the size of securing
distance like it's a number of literals
appearing in the instance so if this
works 0 using somehow like a larger
matter but use a shrinkage the exponent
1.5 so here this work which somehow
makes this matter more trivial as I
improve the shrinkage exponent 2 to be
something larger and then improves the
render time
so what might i mean it is clear why you
put the weight 021 closest but the
intuition is if you have longer causes
then if you do random registration you
have better chance to kill that closed
completely because they're los verbos
appearing again said not Klaus they
don't know fer that's bigger than to
recovery distance between them does of
sorting them better it's only that but
yeah so do you mean that part of the
reason is that would know how to solve
max 2sat yeah that's the Nexus slides so
so this one is essentially a reduction
from Mexico to mex one set but since we
know there exists efficient algorithm
for makes two sets so you can somehow
bill disease brunching by reducing
Mexico Mex to set and I apply Williams
up with form X to set as a bottom levels
so here somehow you can slightly change
these matters basically as intuitions
you put zero mirror or one causes and
two causes and 90 matter are others so
you using this matter you can improve
string kissing is going to two to three
and then improves p and also the run
time but this algorithm requires
exponential space because it was
required by Williams algorithm for max
to set and this still be improved in a
recent work by sake set set o tamaki and
trauma z give algorithm that can solve
max said and polynomial number of
clauses so here is that idea it is also
simple so basically at a high level not
a way to precess but at a high level you
put zero matter and closes young and
mostly less than K wearables and 90 men
are inclusive of lens lodges MK and then
you think that you can buy greedy
restriction you can get a shoe
increasing exponents to be almost ok
over 2 and this K is at your choice you
can choose any Kate you want okay so
for the algorithm I can choose K to be
four times s and then choose P to be
something very small like n to the power
1 or s divided by n so using such
parameters you can assertively you build
this greedy restriction shade you can
reduce mega set to Mexico set so
business at the bottom level for most of
the branches or clauses of lens larger
than K are going to be killed by just
greedy restriction and then you can use
my magician from like this case set as
bottom level so that gives the running
time legacies so the good thing here
might be all for all the previous
examples we have very small shrinkage
exponent like two or three but here you
can really choose a parameter K at the
earth shrinkage in Poland which which
might give you better shrinkage and it
might allow you to solve instances with
larger size now the same algorithm can
be used to replace one step in these
satisfiability algorithm four spot steps
to TC their circuit by this in palazzo
pottery sinead our paper recently so
here i want to reduce the depth of food
stretchable circular with linear number
of wires all the way down to depths to
special circular switch with very few
number of gays so it's also greatly
restriction you you can define marriage
but this marriage extra very trivial it
is the number of wires between the
inputs and the level one special gates
minus the number of days and then you
can buy greedy restriction you can show
a shrinkage exponent which is slightly
larger than one and that will help you
reduce the case from dinner number of
wires too cheesy 0 which very few kids
and then the heart of this I am I PS
approach was actually I already solving
this base case
so in I guess paper it was proved using
different way but using this shrinkage
approach we can somehow give a simpler
proof of their result so it is higher
level if you want to apply this
algorithm a template there might be some
these three things you want to specify
you want to define a mirror on the
instance and you want to show a better
shrinkage exponent and are certain
families of restrictions and then you
want to have some base case algorithms
solving the reduce the distance so also
when you define this Mary you might have
the basic gist adman you so basically
for base case instances you want to put
mayor zero and then you want to give one
mayor as I said you can have the best
the shrinkage exponent so I've shown
some examples but the same approach can
be applied to other cases like
foreigners over for banner basis Mexican
said and also even as far as polynomials
so generations that this this greedy
restriction approach the somehow gives
you a way to reduce short instances for
instances with small ways if you think
of the CNF it gives away very DCF the
kitchen
there are some other users that comes in
changing the shrinkage it can be
combined with other techniques to get
average is the lower bunk and also
pseudo-random generators so that's our
one I want to say thank you very much
good thanks